[Music]
on the show you play a single woman who
is dating and I would think as the boss
you do you get to pick the actors the
male actors that you get to interact
with that's like why I did the show yeah
yeah yeah and it's like on the aleph
it's like I had to you know kiss people
and things like that but in this show
there's like full-on like roll around
make outs and stuff and so I get to cast
those people yeah
but it's it's hard because when I I
don't have like so much experience but
when I've kissed people I find that like
you're you can do it I've kissed enough
men in my life but wouldn't you what I'm
like ruling around making out with
someone in my experience I don't do that
that often where I'm not saying like I
love you to come so it's very hard I
have did not say I love you do like the
actor that I'm doing that with really
you're you have an overwhelming desire
to tell an actor you're something you
love us you better look because you're
like you know you're making out yeah
rolling around are you good at the fake
kissing I mean it's different than real
kissing isn't it it is different the
side I learned in an embarrassing way
which is that when you kiss in real life
when you are feeling passionate you use
your tongue but on TV you're not
supposed to use your tongue yeah you
fake it not supposed to yeah yeah
sometimes if I'm if you're into it I
don't know have you ever had that were
you accidentally start using your yeah
and yeah the first show that me what the
hell are you talking about
it's I was kind of away and he was in
porn in the late night was I was inside
I was in sitcoms where they're like
expecting me to have these like make-out
scenes and I would like I never thought
I'd ever have to do that I was like I'd
have to learn to fall down stairs but
not make out and and yet after take
after take it is you kind of you know
you just like you're kissing someone
yeah and then all of a sudden like and
then the person gets pissed at you it's
like oh come on where's when you're like
the rod come on just like there was just
like a time like one time where the
actress was kind of she was she was just
kind of snippy after and I'm it's not
like I shoved my tongue down her throat
but it just it became a real kid did you
apologize to Betty White that's what
I've been again establish the rules here
so you're saying that you you just slip
the tongue in there yeah yeah and when I
do it on the show now it's like the
worst kind of sexual harassment because
I'm like the boss is that weird but yeah
we can't complain that were like they're
scared to complain it's perfect cause
I'll fight
[Laughter]
in your mouth be quiet about it
perfect the picture I'm painting of
myself yeah it'll be no birthday cakes
you get your shirt off there's some tone
coming your way and shut up about it
you